[Music]
well that's one way to bond Dancing with
the Stars pro Sharna Burgess joined her
fellow dancers and getting their ears
pierced during their New York City stop
for their light up the night tour and
only we were invited exclusively
backstage before they lit up a Radio
City Music Hall
not my first a piercing radio I got
triple and then I didn't expect how much
it was gonna hurt but I liked it
sleeping like a vampire so I didn't I
didn't hate myself not sure how much
sleep Shauna is actually getting on this
tour 61 cities in eat 11 weeks 600
costumes 20 changes per person per show
it's huge
light up the night it also doesn't leave
much time for making wedding plans
Basha and Emmas I Do's are happening too
early this summer and Sasha tells us
he's got two priorities right now hey I
want to be a dad tomorrow but you know
it's all up to him oh this is my kid
right now
Ruby say hi oh my god oh my god move on
to next question I want this night for
Emma to cherish for the rest of her life
and we I'm working on a few little
surprises here and there and it you know
it's gonna be fun right here it's pretty
emotional but when this crew has some
precious downtime what we hear the
ladies like watch The Bachelor jury's
out on what they think of Arie but
they're lobbying hard to get char not
the only single lady in the group on the
show I think
be so straight up and honest and like
not about all these guys like trying to
impress her she would be like nope don't
like you bye
my response is who wouldn't want a bunch
of gorgeous men pining for attention I
guess but at the same time I'm terrified
of that show did you kiss all of them
celebrity dancer Frankie Muniz
definitely not a bachelor his girlfriend
is on tour with him does the only thing
he's missing now is a killer six-pack
I definitely got an amazing shape being
on the show or better shape you know I
mean I eat so bad it's restricted from
getting them should have by now but I
don't know I mean they get all try to
help it yeah you know dogs they're
you're gonna eat hot dogs I mean who's
gonna possible hot dogs not me all right
well how about a real dog because listen
to this there's also this secret animal
game that the dancers play on stage it's
so funny they actually each get assigned
an animal
nobody knows who gets what but at some
point during the show each person has to
make an animal sound to find out who
their animal match is barking and
meowing
[Music]
you